I for screen junkies movie vines today's
episode of movie fights is brought to
you by Squarespace
whether you need a domain website or
online store make it with Squarespace
what's going on everybody movie fights
it's all happening right now
you know if the Internet is good for one
thing it is finding controversy it is a
swirling storm of what how did that
happen in fact that happened right here
on this set during the women in film
event beautiful event raised lots of
money really great cause but some
went down let's go back and take a look
at this moment that will live in infamy
[Laughter]
get out three smart guys three dumb
movies congratulations Joe teeny shout
out to the fader all right
so we had a once-in-a-lifetime matchup
of the three men who were making our
honest trailers right and creating them
and it ended in controversy because we
didn't have a good time for a taker they
were tied one-one one and it came back
to me to decide at night already voted
for Joe star so I just said yeah I guess
I gotta go Joe again so I'm gonna just
put it out there it's a little weird
that a controversy is just me winning
something Dan called foul on that and
you know we're still friend we did not
have a good contingency plan for a time
so today we are super excited not
once-in-a-lifetime twice in a lifetime
we have these three gentlemen oh right
here he's the head writer screen jockeys
you know from honest trailers and all
over the place SJ you Spencer Gilbert
just here to have fun held whose line is
it anyway the points don't matter there
you go there you go thank you for always
having a good time oh man he is the man
with the best hair at screen junkies the
delightful super hilarious Joestar
Spencer got a haircut like like a week
or a week or two ago it's just a good
haircut but you've got product dude you
got like products and we don't even know
about but I need product you don't you
just were all out of bed that way it's
all natural baby I mean that volume no
one's gonna beat that volume brother I
gotta have something in this fight and
he is the man the myth the legend the
king of box office numbers Mr Dan Merle
Dan you're not checking facts today you
came here to kick some ass right here we
go again okay
what's that Bruce Willis no that's
Tropic Thunder okay yes what's your six
I believe again excellent very excited
to have you three doing battle in this
half circle and over on the fact-checked
we got mr. lon Harris mr. Wang long
everybody
LAN you're wearing an owl shirt I am
sure the owls are not what they seem
right on everything's coming up owls
today it's a very heavy show well I
would say a top ten bird yeah I mean
it's throwing it out there I would say a
top five Wow
sitting next to lon oh it's always great
to have she is paranoid about birds
Daniel hey so for those of you just
tuning in a lot of you know how this
works
I am y'all I am the voice of the people
and so in the case of tie between the
judges I will come in and I will read
the YouTube poll there are some really
fun polls on Twitter please join those
join the conversation on Twitter but the
poll that counts is the one on YouTube
it will not go up until every fighter
has made their initial argument we want
this to be about the arguments and not
necessarily about which movie y'all like
more if you're confused about how the
voting works go down in the description
box and if you want to join in
send me really fun things cuz I'm also
on Twitter I'm reading things that stand
out to the sender those who thanked me
babies do that in the hashtag hashtag
movie fights live that is where I will
be I will be checking them and if I
don't have time to necessarily shout out
everyone I do try to like like and fav
and and comment as much as I can
so corgis and as many Korg butts as you
can give me so everybody can see the
corgis yeah give everyone the kisser
just for me Corki supporting everyone
core user for everyone
indeed Spencer I was surprised that you
didn't mock me
saying dankmemes again because I was
getting ready to mock you for wearing a
shirt representing a place that sells
hardcopy media yeah I'll never mock
anything that London Calling says over
there man London Calling College you
know before we kick off this battle let
me I'll break it down real quick again
we have three fighters there are seven
questions first one to four points wins
there are three regular round questions
and then we go to the speed round so
someone's down three Oh going into the
speed round you know someone could still
come back
so don't get comfortable before we kick
off the match Wan as a message for us
yeah before we get into our first round
we do want to thank and shout out our
friends at Squarespace for sponsoring
today's show if you didn't know already
Squarespace makes it's so easy to create
your online identity and that's whether
it's your side gig it's your main hustle
whatever you want to get yourself out
there you want to be on the net it's
never been easier to sell products and
services online and Squarespace is an
all-in-one platform 24-hour customer
service there's nothing to install patch
or upgrade ever it's super easy to use
so you just want to make sure you go to
squarespace.com you can get your free
trial go to Squarespace comm slash movie
fights
that's the secret code get a free trial
and you'll get 10% off your first
purchase of a website or domain lot copy
nice listen sell me this pen yeah see
lon you and I could team up and get a
square face
Squarespace site dedicated to our fandom
of owls junkies come right now I don't
know what's actually there don't
actually go yeah well you could
theoretically someone likes birds in a
very shoe intense all right Juan thank
you for those words jte drop that
package
[Music]
[Applause]
JT a better package than any Apple
product question well-designed
yes number ones go to our first question
what character woo what character would
you want as your attorney if you get an
any movie character what character would
you want is your attorney what a
question
Reese Witherspoon reprising maybe the
greatest role in cinema history yet
again good stuff so Spencer well start
with you
she was actually a good choice and a
front-runner for me but I think there's
only one lawyer in film film history or
actual history who kids out argue her
and that's Abraham Lincoln Lincoln I'm
sorry to reach into the greatest lawyers
of all time to make my pick but I can
choose anyone they made a great film
about him it showed off all of his
lawyerly skills and I'm assuming this is
a defense attorney because it's my
attorney I'm not hiring someone to sue
somebody else that's why I picked
Lincoln he could pass a constitutional
amendment he could get me off the hook
all right Spencer going with an all-time
classic Abraham Lincoln Joe there's more
to love than just knowledge or degree in
law there's also hard work and a
willingness to put in the work and
that's why I'm choosing Tommy Callahan
the third from Tommy Boy this is a guy
who will never stop he'll never let you
down yeah the tram might start a little
rough but he's going to get it together
he's a man of the people he's gonna turn
things around in the most endearing way
possible and win that trial not for
money or for historical fame like
Lincoln but for you because he cares
about people like Honeyboy Lincoln shade
that's selfish Lincoln always happens
yeah we all know Lincoln did it for the
likes um damn I think you want somebody
as your attorney that's got experience
you want somebody that's got a touch of
class you want somebody that the jury's
gonna like and that's why I'm going with
the Matlock of this galaxy and a galaxy
far far away obi-wan Kenobi that one
know which one it was and it's still not
JT is a prequel Paris it's Alec Guinness
that one anyway Alec Guinness is obi-wan
Kenobi is my attorney I think that he
has what it takes to get the job done
I think he has the experience that it
takes and I look forward to defending
his honor to your honors here and your
honors at home if it please the court
okay once again we have Abraham Lincoln
Tommy Callahan the third from Tommy Boy
and obi-wan Kenobi fight it out fellas
I trust obi-wan as a judge and you know
why is because he sees that there's two
sides to everything he's the master of
seeing the lightness and the dark he's
too wishy-washy to actually make a
convicted defense on behalf of someone
or or convinced himself to be part of
the prosecution he's too afraid of
commitment too afraid of throwing
himself into the fight he always wants
to just stand back and kind of judge
from a distance that's not what you
wanted a lawyer I'm concerned about
trusting a guy that's lived in a cave in
the desert for the past 20 years like
where is his head space at as he enters
the courtroom with you you're right you
want to trust a guy who's strapped road
flares to his chest who threatened to
blow up the building now just the guy
that took seven years to get through
undergraduate by doing bond grabs and
blasting out of these seven years of
college that's four years undergrad
three years law school that's nice
they're called doctors I remember that
snarky David Spade lie Joe you can't get
that one past I think something big
about being an attorney is being able to
sell it's about that opening arguments
about that closing argument and Tommy
can sell hey if you want me to take a
dump in a box and market guaranteed I
will or you buy a quality product from
me that's his first sell it's great
there's no transition part is dad's line
that is not Tommy Callahan fine that was
his father's line but it taken it's
taking him what he learned from his
father really getting into the gear like
I said I didn't say this trial is gonna
perform the get go but this is a guy
that will not stir I'm gonna end the
trial by bailing my own lawyer out of
jail to have him continue he's he's got
an anger problem he goes with his gut
and yes that can be that could be good
folk a psych eval is embargoing angry
anger issues Lincoln a bare-knuckle
brawler entered politics was wrestling
who's a sanctioned about entered
politics to solve what he called his own
personal national debt in it for the
money Tommy Callahan is for the people
it's ours we use a different for winning
control of the company no no he was in
it to make sure hit those people had
jobs he's a man of the people he's a
blue-collar guy he's he's in there he's
not he's not a president up there in his
is he's nepotism you you're asking for
Eric Trump to defend you in court you're
getting this guy who carries everything
in his life
and yes he got it together at the very
last possible set when it counts the
movie about lawyers if you want to talk
about the imperfect ending can we talk
about how he actually managed to close
the big deal and save this company
what's he like relationships I used to
fake terrorist incident and a bank he's
there be on trial it's not gonna be
defending you and I don't want my lawyer
to go after his closing arguments a turn
to the jury and go let me tell you why I
suck as a lawyer he's gonna
the road is so relatable that jury is
gonna be like I get this guy I'm like
look is open one even gonna finish the
trial or is he gonna turn into clothes
to teach you a lesson that's a concern
for me I just turn into clothes on a
whim Joe I'm sorry obi-wan Kenobi you
were watching I'm sorry the judges like
are you representing yourself here like
oh no the living force is representing
me maybe I'm sure someone knows crow
being the expanding universe forever but
on screen he has a record of failure
when it comes to negotiation is
negotiate with the Trade Federation fell
apart is negotiated with his own padawan
fell apart he had to take the high
ground just to get out of their life his
negotiations were never the problem it
was the fact that he was willing to deal
with these people that were the problem
he went to the table he went to the
table with offers that means that he has
experience in these negotiate a briefing
today to his team of rivals he convinced
his most bitter enemies to support some
of those against their own self-interest
that's what you want
hidden do that he bullied this cabinet
to go.you James Spader was one that was
out there in the swamps getting people
to change their ropes link it was up
Baxley we get the pins his voice is so
annoying I want to put it on pause for
one second real quick Dan hold that
thought I want to hear from each of you
what crime are you being defended for
what crime did you commit in this yes
let's go down this unrelated road for
just a moment tell us what crime you're
being defended for
well okay so I wouldn't wanna yeah had a
good head of steam huh shoplifting all
of us were on trial for shoplifting oh
all on trial for chocolate yeah sure
it's me shoplifting yes here's the thing
about obi-wan Kenobi you say that he's
worried she should be a judge and not a
lawyer no Kenobi is like the most
lawyerly person in the world because I
want a guy who will defend me whether
I'm guilty or not he's my lawyers part
of the job that every lawyer should
you're right that is part of the job
what's gonna hand the way that obi-wan
Kenobi doesn't in the way that he stages
a convincing argument is that to him
everyone is justified in doing something
from a certain point of view that is the
most lawyerly thing in the world from
the certain points of view from a
certain point of view
I left your dad on a lava bank to die
however I'm gonna sell it to you is the
good thing because from a certain point
of view I'm right that's what you need
in a lawyer he takes out that passivity
paralyzes him okay you're gonna have
going back to that well can't smoke so
he stands back well the Senate takes
power like he's always just no let's
hold back and you can just imagine the
other lawyer going after a witness and
you're just looking at obi-wan like are
you gonna say objective you don't well
tend to fear wouldn't want upset the
balance of the culture dear traveler
shop today if you're on trial for
shoplifting that guy has someone else's
lightsaber in a trunk in his house he
himself as a thief oh that guy tried to
kill always do closing arguments okay
great
watching we were going man all right
should we make
[Applause]
I show this is gone go ahead and give us
the facts I got every boat backseat
check there are some Lincoln the
implication that link it was only doing
things for historical favors actually
been taken up by a number of prominent
historians Elizabeth Brown priors six
encounters with Lincoln does imply that
Lincoln was a narcissist
whereas Emery college psychological
scientist Scott lively failed he says
that Lincoln was only our 31st most
narcissistic president there's a lot
even in the movie his wife well we're
done arguing we stumbled into something
that actually has a lot of impact
tommy-boy
did go to college for seven years as an
undergrad basically there was not law
school included we're very clear about
that but to add one more thing about
Tommy he is very explicitly worried in
the film about the employees losing
their jobs he brings that up very often
that was all the facts I heard there was
one thing that didn't get mentioned I
was very curious to hear what the answer
would be is obi-wan gonna use the Jedi
mind
yeah I mean it went over ten minutes
argument went over ten minutes it was
lingering out there that I was curious
about that's all I had I had it well
that being said Spencer your obi-wan
sounded a little too much like Paul
McCartney for my tastes
I really liked where you're coming from
with like Tommy Boy winning everybody
over but I thought there were some great
takedowns on you as far as him like
staging a terror like a terrorist threat
and which borrowing from his father and
yeah might not be the most reliable
lawyer and dad I thought there was some
good takedowns as far as the Obi Wan's
record of failure as a negotiator I
thought I thought that the least amount
of takedowns came against Spencer and he
parried nicely and for that I go Abraham
[Music]
Lincoln all the time yeah Jill made a
lot of good audience but there were a
lot of takedowns that sort of went
unanswered so for me it ended up being
between Spencer's death but I I have to
differ with you I got Dan's response
about from a certain point of view that
is extraordinarily lawyerly language I
found that to be a very convincing
obi-wan could sort of put himself in a
mindset to think whoever he was
defending deserves to get off that's
very important so I'm going with them
all right one one one one
Danielle Radford let's go to the
internet to decide let's go to the
Internet so we have got a blink in it
52% obi-wan specifically New Hope 34%
and Tommy Callahan at 12% Oh
once the Internet didn't let me down as
a former paralegal this is very weird
for me a lot of opinions yeah yeah many
opinions from you or from people
watching any lawyers and everyone real
cranking and y'all picked Atticus Finch
biggest case yeah
[Laughter]
movie fighter I would have gone people
who were going with Vinnie Gambini Pesci
and Fred Gailey from your 64th Street
got a couple Tom Cruise from a few good
men I didn't see any good men I think
mostly cause it's like I don't know dude
like yelled out I don't know there's one
on Twitter at gunner 921 said Johnny
from the room perfect defense he did not
do it it's not true you're tearing him
apart
oh hi Josh awesome Danielle thank you
for that also please chime in with what
you think Joe Joe Spencer and Dan each
shop lifted I want to know what you
think each of them shop lifted question
number two isn't one thank you Oh
Spencer
spooky question who's the scariest movie
ghost who is the scariest movie ghost
and we will start with player number two
Joestar hello with the the specific
poltergeist that is controlling that
clown in the movie poltergeist I just
think there's something really
inherently from the 2015 remake oh yeah
JT is getting a lot of flack he is
yelling back from the booty did not pull
the sighs you're an easy target
I'm just saying the whole controversy is
cuz I won you guys put me in the sinking
chair you gave me the wrong clown and
ship I'm literally sinking poltergeist
Connor something inherently scary about
both dolls and clowns
it is a Venn diagram of the two there's
just something weird and uncanny valley
and very off-putting about them
something that I find more scary in in a
horror movie is less is more don't show
me as much as the monster don't do so
much and the just there's something very
scary about your imagination making
choices for you it makes the worst
scariest possible choices for you and
that's what the clown does kid throws a
thing at the clown your brain decides
that how that clown is getting angrier
and angrier instead of the screen
showing it to you and that's scarier
than anything the screen can show so
clown
alright the poltergeist clown Dan oh my
god
I went with the ghost that has that
scared me the trailers to this movie
scared me I'm not I'm not good with
ghosts and that is kiya Co the the
vengeful spirit from The Grudge both of
the original and the American series of
films I think what's scary about ghosts
for me the most is that they can be
anywhere like there's no you can't stop
them you can't keep them out there
anywhere and I think that the way that
they takashi shimizu did this particular
ghost is how they staged it where she
can be she can be you know like the one
that i always go back to is in bed and
she's like under the covers like staring
at you or you're in the shower it taps
so primally into these everyday
situations and she will just appear and
that for me is scary it's not so much
who oh I look scary and I jumped out at
you it's this idea of an evil spirit
permeating your everyday life that's
what kept me awake at night just from
the images that they used to sell this
movie not not to mention the images in
the movies themselves and that's what
puts the grudge and knock it off at
opening argument you're already spooking
me out very spoopy Spencer well I
believe it was brett erlich
that famously argued the ghost he'd most
like to be haunted by was the
ghost in ghostbusters I'm arguing a
different tact the scariest ghost in
film at night actually this really did
affect me is the BJ Baer in the shining
the
only one shining so far appears at the
end of the shining of fellating a ghost
of a hotel manager that used to run the
place and it comes in the middle of just
such a escalating series of of weirdness
and and off-putting imagery that this
just puts it all the way over the edge
for me it's so unexpected it's such a
shocking image it's so disturbing and
then if you want to really go down the
kubrik details and theories and stuff
like that the it's scary without knowing
anything about it and the more you learn
about it the scarier it gets alright
three scary ghosts fight it out you guys
I mean your pick is basically with ten
seconds of screen time and I've never
really thought it was necessarily scary
it's certainly weird it's odd it's
bizarre I think that the room 237 ghosts
is scary I think the little girls in the
hallway are scary I think this is just a
very kind of bizarre image I wouldn't
call it the scary certainly at the
scariest ghost I think he's more if this
was the most put up on ghost
I think BJ bear would win because he's
just trying to give a guy a bj and then
this lady just runs in screaming and
he's like right not even aggressive
they're like yeah thank you how they
seem I seem a little less perturbs and
perhaps even a non ghost would be and in
that situation well okay just to briefly
gloss over the backstory in the book
it's a sex slave situation so it's not
Rebecca book consensual situation but
the Stanley Kubrick made an interesting
choice he changed it from a dog to a
bear now why did he do that where does
the other bear imagery appear on Danny's
pillow while he's sleeping and above
Danny's bed on the bear implying that
Danny was not only physically but
sexually abused as a kid so this is a
really creepy detail to add to this
that's sad well you can go satis ghosts
don't you go make a documentary about
that Spencer and is it a bear I think
it's still with dogs it's lunch I don't
look at it it may look like a bear I
think it might still be a dog whatever
either way yeah well I think that
thinking that a ghost is gonna stand
over my bed at a 90 degree angle above
me when I sleep it's a little scarier
than possible subtext and
inaudible that wasn't very contained in
the movie itself so weird imagery coming
into the poltergeist clown because again
it's like the imagination I what's left
what's left of the imagination with the
poltergeist clown it's a clown mm-hmm
and it pops out and that's that's the
end of that's the end of its haunt the
beginning of that is just all tension
all tension building tension building
tension until boom it's the inevitable
time before the clam the clown scarier
when it's inanimate than when it's
moving around because if you follow that
clown through to the end of its lifespan
it gets killed by a tiny boy but I would
say that versus the grudge this ghost is
a one-and-done it's scary boom it
doesn't go back to the well for a series
of diminishing same with the shining so
it's a one and done thing although
Pennywise from it certainly takes the
scary clown thing to a more creepy level
some clowns a few big adventure scary
the problem with the grudge is
diminishing returns now you're not a
poor guy neither am i but even i've seen
more than one grudge movie and there are
check notes eleven of them there are so
many grudge movies and they have the
same kayako scares of her with the
broken neck crawling around the thing
over and over again that she's the
impact is lost no it's a great trailer
and actors lost than why they still make
in the movies transformers they still
making paranormal activities they're not
diminishing I was curious if you're
gonna go with the American remake or the
original and the American the big
climactic scary moment with her coming
down the stairs there are shots of it
that just looked like they have a
mannequin on its stomach and a PA is
pushing it right from right off camera
don't even there forget the American
remake she ended up fighting the ghost
from the ring in like a Freddy vs. Jason
movie actually brought a clip JT you
want to run that clip
so she ended up that's very you it was
scary initially and now it's become like
Sharktopus it was scary initially thank
you and that's my point if you want to
say they ran it into the ground you can
say they ran it in the ground that's
fine that's an argument that you can
make it doesn't take away from the fact
that that goes to scary and I don't go
like oh they use certain eight other
movies
I'm retro actively not scared anymore
the fact that the way that she was
introduced in the way that she's still
employed some of those we're sitting
right on the ground you can say that the
fact that they are able to employ that
ghost in such a scary thing and again
it's not the thing if I'm in a haunted
house I'm in you know there's this weird
guy or whatever there's there's this
there's a stuffed animal it's the idea
of this this everyday life being
intruded upon by the spirit you can't
kill it you think you can kill it it's a
curse it follows you you can't escape it
from it every hunted house that's every
ghost story is like it's a grudge
holding spirit from beyond the execution
of it is is not scary and that that's
what frustrates me about the great
concept but like the noises and scary
it's just irritating
[Music]
they keep every time they can't they
keep saying mind ghosts tonight scary
I'm telling you why both of yours aren't
that scary and you said loudly right
into the ground well it's not scary
anymore well the ghost does carry to me
the fact of the matter is that it is
employed the best cinematically it's the
scariest ghost and it's the way that
it's you know you said it before you see
it the worse the effects get the more
boring the effects get that's why I like
the poltergeist clown because your
imagination doesn't work for you that's
scarier than anyone who's due to life
it's not scary anymore it's got this big
Muppet tendril like flopping around and
then the kid rips it to pieces you're
talking about that effects I'm sorry
you're gonna revisit the effects in the
original poltergeist on that clown and
tell me that that's not easily I will
take those cheesy practical effects over
bad CGI grudge it's just it just doesn't
look good it doesn't look scary but
that's a little boy he might have bought
the clown but at least at least that
haunting came to a conclude that's
that's boo penis came to a conclusion
yours was just a guy that was like dude
I've got a dick in my mouth can you go
away so I can finish this up later
there's different levels to frightening
there's the I think the grudge and this
one both falling why are you so scared
of dog dancer dicks in their mouths Penn
Central and they're based on dead messed
up there's the signs are there dammit
signs were all there
alright let's go to lawn Harris with the
fact-checking lawn much chimed in with
your opinions on this oh not a lot of
facts to check it was too vague you know
pretty subjective round but what people
find scary I have to say as much as I
love the shining oh there is there is a
lot of disagreement online about whether
that is a bear or a dog there's there's
no definitive Kubrick did not say it was
like John Candy's barf I always thought
it was a bear but a lot of people as
Barry
[Laughter]
that's coming towards your groin what is
the most unsettling imagery of a ghost
or what ghost has the best sort of
backstory but I don't think he really
sold me on the scariness it was between
Jo and Dan I thought they both made a
lot of good points I personally like the
practical effects in poltergeist I still
think it looks fun but I feel like Dan
really made a solid case for how The
Grudge uses a ghost and why it's so
scary to see it in everyday situations I
thought that was a really good point so
I go dick
all right that's a 1 for Dan yeah
Spencer I love how you took us down that
road of how all the math of ending up at
that character works and now I want to
go back and watch that and piece
together that puzzle myself that being
said it was a weird jarring moment but
yeah it wasn't quite the scariest but it
came down to a Jo and Dan for me as well
and I just heard more from Dan I don't
think you sold us on the piece by piece
and dance opening salvo was super strong
and then I think he parried all of
everything yeah yeah like he painted
that picture of this ghost that you
could not get away from I also got to go
Dan so Dan gets the point
Danielle what people say started this
round that it was a bear I feel like
I've learned something today today's the
day I became a woman so a 63% we've got
kayako from the grad sorry if I
butchered that 23% we've got the
poltergeist clown and in 12% coming in
hot is BJP
any votes for Large Marge a lot of
people said Patrick Swayze in ghost is
emotionally Friday also said Casper
homes the underscore 83 said I'd be
scared of ghosts dog was coming after
following the way of the bushido he's
only going after if you deserve it
damn that's a new spin on ghosts though
so so far for shoplifting everyone has
agreed that it's just Dan taking a lot
of flannel shirts and hats a great
player came in and said he only wears
FSU hats and they give them away for
free so who gives one away for free FSU
bet apparently no FSU if you're watching
that's alright it is a one for Dan one
for Spencer and we are heading into the
third round this is inspired by the
wreckit-ralph two trailer pitch a movie
that set inside the internet pitch a
movie that's set inside the internet
question number three starting with
player number three Dan Merle mmm this
was a this was tougher than I
anticipated just cuz it's like how do
you not do you've done the emoji movie
and wreck-it Ralph - and what are you
doing so I was kind of sick what's
something that I think would bring a new
dimension to it and the the concept that
I came up with is called dark web Wow
stars Toni Collette and Oscar Isaac and
their two parents who I mean it's very
Lynch E and so it's kind of hard to
describe the plot of it but the ascent
to the basics of it is that they have
this kid who's like an internet troll
and he gets basically absorbed by the
Internet and so they have to go kind of
in search of him but as with all David
Lynch movies that's a rough outline for
what exactly the movie is
what it it really Maura's is I just love
how singular david lynch's i don't
always get what he's doing but it's such
a unique way of looking at things and i
really am just interested in his take on
this weird if there's anything more
surreal than David Lynch it's the
internet and so I want to see his take
on this weird world of consumerism and
entertainment and news and commerce all
blending together the dark side of it
the dark humor that's that's in a lot of
it I just think it would be really
interesting and in a way that I don't
know how many concepts are left and the
technology side that was still be
interesting so it was something that I
would be interested in seeing alright
David Lynch is David Lynch's dark web
from Dan background Spenser I also
thought about something I'd be
interested in seeing you guys remember
the y2k bug I do yeah everyone thought
all the network devices were gonna fail
and all the planes would fall out of the
sky and it passed and we all thought it
was a big joke but that's cuz you guys
don't know the full story
no but you'll find out in why to kill
upload a prayer download a dream it's
December 1999 America's top scientists
tell an exosuit wearing Al Gore that y2k
is gonna take down the world and there's
nothing they can do about it out of
options he assembles a crack team of
celebrity cyber commandos to hack the
internet itself and set off an a-bomb
that changes the digits from two to four
enter a digital EDH james van der beek
Tom Green and drew Barrymore the root
Squad celebrities by day Navy SEAL
hackers of training in ninjutsu by night
and they're gonna fight their way to the
central clock of the 90s web by any
means necessary that's my opening pitch
for why to kill Wow oh man I can't
imagine there's some there's more
there's more very exciting why to kill
upload a prayer download a dream got it
Joe Stark well this is one of those cool
situations where we all came into just
blind pitch each other and really
surprised each other and also one of
those situations when maybe that wasn't
the best idea my movie is called cash it
is directed by David Lynch
this is gonna be fun actually I think
I'm going yeah the kind of psychological
horror thriller black mirror Meets The
Shining so my pitch is a team of
software engineers are sent virtually
into a social media network in the
not-too-distant future which means like
Michael Stu Park and Naomi Watts and
Steve Yun and Winston Duke what a great
cast so in the not-too-distant future
there's just there's just one sort of
monolithic social media network they
have to patch a glitch in the system the
network reacts as if they're intruders
and traps them in a digital haunted
house built around their lifetime of
social interactions so that means
anything they've ever done on the
Internet whether it's a positive simple
innocent thing like they played the same
song on a loop for a month or if it's
something gross like they trolled the
out of someone and like you know
drove them to move out of their house or
something like that all of that is fair
game and coming to life and you know
sort of being presented back to them
it's a it's a haunted house that they've
built for themselves and this network
has them trapped in it all right you
know and just the fact that you both
chose Lynch doesn't matter it's the
better pitch the how you fit Lynch into
it etc so each one will be judged by its
individual merits fight it out everybody
well entering the internet is a stupid
idea so it's it's always gonna be this
cuttle the same thing that happens with
Tron the same thing that happens like
lawnmower man where you just thrown out
techno garbage let's do a
tongue-in-cheek self-aware version of
that where like you're taking everything
you love about hackers and everything
it's cheesy about these movies and just
embracing it and going back to like the
fun part of nostalgia that not the ready
player one stuff but the but the time
has come from late 90s nostalgia pixels
pick not pixels pixels feel no
no it's not pixels you must see James
frame to beat fighting neo pet yeah you
all see yes sounds old pixel a
completely different tone this is like
oh yeah a bunch of washed-up 90 stars
fighting nineties things it's like Team
America
it's like embracing the tropes of the
genre and of this era to make like kind
of a winking like isn't this dumb wasn't
this a more innocent time movie but
Neopets weren't even connected to the
internet Spencer what Tamagotchis dipper
game up Joe I'm a 90s kid and as those
references have already been lost on me
so like what need do I have to go see
this film like yeah it's the best parody
movie of 2002 we're just making in 16
years later yeah I don't I don't have a
nostalgia for that and that's that
should be in my target zone like oh I'd
love to see that I'm just like no no no
thank you
that's why why do we need to go back to
y2k it's about a family that had a kid
that's a troll right yes okay so our
odds are fairly similar with what I like
about a group of adults being trapped in
something like this is that you have
more of a lifetime of experiences than
just a kid who specifically a troll and
so it's gonna be less of a revenge thing
you were bad trolling is bad and more of
just just a sort of a study of humanity
almost just people's choices whether
they be good or bad being twisted and
turned against them and like you it's a
you know David Lynch is going to give
you a lot more than what you're
expecting is any of this real what's
going on it's gonna be just a really
sort of dark and twisted puzzle box
movie that people are gonna obsess with
like his other ones I think we're going
both this premise of going inside the
computer I know mine sounds stupid and
jokey but anything you do with that
premise is gonna come off as stupid and
jokey so trying to make a prestige film
about going inside the Internet I think
that's why I am going way more that's
why I picked David Lynch director in a
setting and he's a David Lynch he'll
make it cool
because the question literally says pick
a team a director and a setting and a
cast which I know nothing yeah no that's
when we got what I mean exactly yeah
yeah that's the things like the job was
to pitch a movie set in the Internet and
my the thing that I did was like I
didn't I specifically want the David
Lynch and my premise because you're
right it has a lot of avenue to be
cheesy but I also think and the reason
that I went with my approach is and
where Jose and I differ is you've
constrained David lunch too much and
that you're painting them in the black
mirror box and I saw a great episode of
black mirror that was about replaying
your life and everything's recorded and
you can play it back and see it like
that kind of stories been done that's
why I went with a very loose construct
because the only thing left with this
concept is something weird and trippy
and out there and it's not so much about
the internet itself like it's not a
premise German movie in the sense like
it's about people going in it it's a
David hates technology David Lynch
exactly he's hated for so long he
doesn't understand it enough to even
comment on it this is a guy who hates
iPhones he's like I don't watch a movie
on your goddamn phone he's like a
Luddite like he's not the person to take
on the flaws of the internet no first he
is a Luddite and he's the perfect person
to take on the flaws of the internet
because he's coming at it as now that's
a circle it's like people who don't get
social media can't make fun of social
media that you can avoid it but like let
him just I don't think my pitch is
limited by David Lynch not not having a
hot take understanding of snapchat nor
is it limited by the gimmick of the
Internet this is at its the setting is
the Internet but the core is people
coming face-to-face with a lifetime of
choices how those have shaped them are
they good are they bad how do they deal
with them look I I'm still anxiety
driven because I thought my wedding
reception playlist was bad like that'll
still come up so imagine David Lynch
taking something as simple and silly as
that and just wrapping it around
somebody turning them inside out and
making them deal with it a really good
psychological drama yes the Internet is
the vehicle but it's not a gimmick
imagine the creepy dancing baby from
Ally McBeal eating drew Barrymore and
then james van der beek makes the crying
james van der beek memphis that sound
that sounds like the Robot Chicken
Seltzer whatever epic movie that sounds
like a sketch that would be in one of
those god-awful 2002 it's like oh what's
the dance and baby thinking about that
shut up Dawson like that was awful 10
years ago how each but yours is way
better yep it's gonna be great in every
90's ever ever video but about a minute
left about a minute left but see so
that's I think with with an with an
ensemble cast with this being focused on
an ensemble of adults I think that gives
you more to play with than just a kid
who's a troll that sounds more like just
sort of a straight-up like kind of
revenge thing like this is what you get
for that's not what it is that's not
what that's not what the message of the
movie is that is the setup that's the
vehicle to which we get into this movie
and the thing about David Lynch is you
talk about an ensemble cast like I have
a couple good actors Oscar Isaac and
Toni Collette I picked them because
they've done really good work and very
experimental films before and I think
that they would go well Flint's because
the star of a David Lynch movie is David
Lynch and the more that you focus on the
cast and the story and the plot and what
these people are going through the less
you get away from I gave him what
someone who he works with regularly
someone who he conduits David Lynch
through Naomi Watts it's one of his
muses I think that that's a really good
casting decision so yeah of course he's
the star he's the lead this is a cast
that knows how to sort of get out of his
way and be used to tell the story that
he wants to tell I think Christopher
Nolan could you could do sort of what
you're talking about where it's like
yeah it's a boring internet thing but
the difference in David Lynch doing a
project like this is bringing up that
raw emotion and terror and just general
discomfort about how great David Lynch's
you're both just stepping away from the
premise itself and - is going it's a
nostalgic throwback to a bar nostalgic
better time where it's little more
innocent on the internet and off of it
and it's just a fun adventure movie
through a computer hi alright David
Lynch he's a bit of a
the Internet's been doing a lot of
experiments on the internet all along
here's a quote it's just sort of
starting but it's a beautiful world a
beautiful modern world and getting
better kind of an internet fan but worth
pointing out as for the pitches Spencer
I have to say hide me for a while but
then when we got down to the stretch and
it was dancing baby Vanderbeek meme
references yeah it does sound like a
scary movie kind of thing and I you kind
of lost me on that or something a
psychotic fan would say yes come down to
the two Lynch's and I think you know
like they both sound interesting as a
big David Lynch man I think I have to in
the end go with cash I really like the
idea of a haunted house that is
determined by your own past Internet
activity and search history feels really
relevant right now like a troll being
confronted by the horror of their own
actions so I'm going with Joe gotcha
thanks lon
yeah I got to agree with you on
Spencer's it did sound like yeah just I
the tone like that's a bitter it's a
tough pill to swallow you got to be you
really got to want to see a bunch of
nineties references and it's worst it
could be a little bit epic movie ish no
one wants to see a movie in the Internet
so it also came down to the lynches for
me but I went a little bit different
from you on because I like both of these
pitches as potential movies but damn
sounded more Lynch Ian to me like Dan's
the one that was evocative of what Lynch
does best like the last couple into
movies I saw Inland Empire and
Mulholland drives Mahon Drive which are
real mind effers Dan kind of took me
down that road and I want to give David
Lynch the tools to succeed here even
though that's a compelling movie with
great casting choices dan seemed just
more fully realized to me in a lynchin
way so I got to go Dan we're 1:1 let's
go to Daniel Radford it's the Battle of
the Lynch's who will Lynch harder so
Cole we have got with 56% Joe's pitch
for cash with 24% we've got Dan's pitch
and
insert caiman is a very respectable 19%
is outdoor playing himself yes notes
everyone is like really into all of your
movies from what I'm seeing on the thing
Joe is married even though I feel like
he talks about it a whole bunch a lot of
people like asking for a friend that's
like nuts all right it's the hair Easter
thirst is in her character and yeah
those are some of the great ones that I
saw everyone was like super into this
round you guys nice good nicely done Joe
takes it that means we've got a
three-way tie
tiebreaker use the one we had a
last-second audible one before the show
we were all discussing it we were all
talking about before the show I don't
know if you all right we don't we all
words you we already are when you're
talking about trying to think about it
think about it okay
so since there are three of you the the
first answer will go first the second
answer will go second the third person
to call it out will go third and are we
giving just a strict 20 seconds or we
gonna do a 10 second rebuttal as well
Billy he says okay 20 and 10 20 and 10
all right here's the tiebreaker
what terry gilliam movie would be most
improved if you added the entire Justice
League to the cast
okay with Brazil
did he direct Holy Grail no Terry
Johnson thank you
well I'll get the co-direct of it I
don't know how you decide if you want to
go either
did he co-director they co-directed it
ok we'll allow it
Holy Grail all right but I'll go with 12
monkeys all right nice okay so Daniel go
third Joey will go second and Spencer
your time will start whenever you speak
the cinematic Justice League the one we
have to this point which is the one I'm
working with works best in a techno
dystopia these people work the best in a
world that's controlled a world where
people are tortured a world full of
darkness and grimness and they're always
just grimacing and they're always
paranoid and that's the perfect setting
for the Justice League for the Justice
League that we know and currently deal
with don't you want to see patent time
Joe
I think it's a terrible idea to just do
more dark Justice League but if you put
them in something as ridiculous as Monty
Python on the Holy Grail then you can
skewer the commercialism of the Justice
League the failed iconography of the
Justice League just the failing attempts
at making them a thing the entire movie
is about this ridiculous failed quest it
runs so many parallels with the DCU's
attempt to make itself a thing
it ends in complete cop outs shots fired
at DCU Dan look at 12 monkeys and look
what it's all about it's about it's
about avoiding this horrific future
that's ahead of us what would make the
stakes even higher than adding even more
Bruce Willis except now there's Jason
Momoa run around saying yeah Dark Knight
nightmares and things flying around like
oh my god that's even more terrifying it
ups the stakes even more and I think
that's what you want you want Terry
Gilliam to use that iconography those
things look like
alright so now we'll go around and hear
your 10 second rebuttals Spencer
whenever you're ready
so the question was most improved and
Dan yet they fit in that movie they fit
in my movie but yours is a comedy and
nothing ruins comedy like the Justice
League like the current DC EU there's
not a single joke that works in that
entire universe and to put them in holy
grails secondly to put them in holy
girls the only direction you can take
them now put Jason Momoa in front of the
Knights that's a knee and just watch his
like cool swagger just shatter in front
of this ridiculous scene they're so
over-the-top this is where they live you
just completely derailed a classic
comedy and threw Jason Momoa in there
and ruin to that movie whereas Spencer
and I have both incorporated the Justice
League into our movies without affecting
the overall quality I feel we've
improved them you've completely derailed
the whole Arthur thing time Wow
what a weird question
and superhero movie gotcha
there is relevance there all right
Danielle Radford's oh and let we pick
pick the one who does not who does Yahoo
does mom doesn't pick the one who does
not the people it's just the voice of me
yes being real said I love you all um so
everyone had really good points this was
a really silly question for sure strong
arguments ah this is really hard but I
do have to say that I agree with as much
as I would love to watch all of these
characters just get completely taken
down and and the Holy Grail I do agree
that it winds up Dee railing the story
of it as much as I do want to have that
moment of Jason Momoa just coming in on
swaggy and drunk and then getting cut
down it does take away from the story
completely um so I have to say I hate
everything don't make me do it
yeah you know what Danielle I hate to do
it because we sugar Danielle I only feel
you demonstrate a terry gilliam recall
and I thought you did find jobs infusing
these characters into potential
scenarios but yeah I think Dan had just
a great takedown on you at the end
saying that it does derail what's an
amazing comedy and yeah for that reason
I'm sad to do it but Joe you are not
going to this video it's been a pleasure
sir mr. moral see ya after the show just
lower your chair we'll come if you got
it yeah if you got some thoughts
oh just like gary oldman and tiptoes
it's just like Gary Oldman okay Dan and
Spencer are locked up in a 1-1 tie here
we go folks
speed round time and again Danielle will
not be reading the Internet's opinion
for the poll she'll be giving her own
opinion because there's no time for
polls in the speed round here is
question number one this comes from
someone who donated to our women in film
event lizzie Heffernan Thank You Lindsay
Lindsay asks which here we go
which gary oldman performance would be
most improved by being performed on his
knees a lot tiptoes folks wait no that's
I've seen Gary Busey Wow Zaira is that
his name the pimp in true romance okay
yeah drexel
drexel look at him from true romance
okay
Commissioner Gordon all right Spencer
spoke first with Drexel from true
romance so 20 seconds begins whenever
you speak now I think it adds to
drechsel's character because he's just
this collection of quirks of insane
quarks that shouldn't work together but
they do he's Gary Oldman a white English
guy with dreads who talks into patois
with gold teeth and a weird Hawaiian
shirt why not make him bow on his knees
to one more layer of oddness and I'll
bet you could do some cool action stuff
with a guy on his knees fighting
Christian Slater in close quarters with
a shotgun time alright whenever you are
ready you ever heard of put the Hat on
hats he has so many quirks last thing he
needs is another quirk you're right he
has so many other things going for him I
want to see Carrie Coleman just being
towered over by Batman what symbol
Batman towers over the Gotham police
department than him literally towering
over his Commissioner James Gordon
now the Hat on the hat a hat thing isn't
a distraction because like you said he's
already a collection of quirks that is
adding like the weirdness to it where
like you can't even frame the two
characters together you're gonna have to
shoot from this wide angle just to see
them both he's gonna be a Batman's waist
again you're there's a stylistic reason
for it you're impressing Batman sighs
plus Gary only can do anything he will
still be a great character and it's just
too much it's like tacky wallpaper on
top of green paint it's too much time
all right
Wow both great arguments but I think
ultimately I think Drexel already has a
ton going on and I think it would be a
really interesting take on those scenes
we've seen through so many Batman movies
if Batman was legitimately towering over
or on his knees Commissioner Gordon I'm
going with them all right that's one for
Dan Danielle I have to I have to agree
with a little commish dan gets that
point it is to one to one in the speed
round second question of the speed round
oh and Joe starts over there looking
hella adorable
give us a Commissioner Gordon line
[Laughter]
alright question number two val kilmer
will likely return for Top Gun - what
other role would you want to see him
revisit in like a sequel or just like in
life what other role would you want to
make a movie where he died revisit okay
whatever I'm bein mad Mart again and J
teen like that in a willow mad Morgan
and Willow I'm gonna go with let's keep
it on theme I'm gonna go with that man
alright we as Batman we have mad Mart
again Spencer you smoke first begin
whenever you're feeling it I'm also
keeping it on theme with little people
it's a fantasy movie it's unique and man
Martin is absolutely the best part of
that film he adds so much a verb and so
much life and spirit to it he's the
ultimate charming rogue who you can't
trust as far as you can throw him he's a
Val Kilmer's perfect for that he's got a
devilish glint in his eye and I'd love
to see him come back to that role maybe
a little wizened a lo later like a han
solo time yeah I don't want to go to Val
Kilmer over the past I'm gonna go with
the Val Kilmer of the present and this
is something the Batman series which is
sorely in need of some rejuvenation is
never done they have never returned to
an actor who had the role to return and
do something new with it and I want to
see how val kilmer who is a fantastic
actor that doesn't get a lot of work for
challenges these days manages to take a
Batman from what he did into this new
current situation if he was such a
fantastic actor I agree he is but he
flubbed Batman why would you give him a
second chance of return to a world that
no one wants to see him return to he was
stiff as a board and there's no reason
why there's any depth if he's the same
Batman from the forever universe I'm
blue that's my point though he's not you
were taking him back to the character
and he didn't flub Batman people people
say that he did but he didn't he
actually was one of the more
psychologically complex Batman up there
with Keaton way better than cloning
better than a lot of other people that
have had the wrong time this is a very
difficult choice here by the way no one
said the correct answer Doc Holliday but
that's a top secret
you know what Spencer had a takedown of
Dan that Dan navigated but Dan didn't
really have any takedowns
for men marred again that really
resonated for me so I got a go Spencer
on this one let's go to lon yeah it was
pretty close but yeah I thought I didn't
hear any real solid arguments about why
sort of revisiting mad Mart again willow
- wouldn't work I feel like it kind of
would so I'm going with Spencer as well
all right Spencer gets the point we are
locked up at 2:00 - Wow not biased
engineers all right question number
three of the speed round the new
Halloween trailer drops tomorrow besides
the original Halloween what's the best
ever movie featuring Jamie Lee Curtis
[Music]
question lies okay true lies a lot of
good movies Wow
well I'm gonna go with the Trading
Places Trading Places all right did you
in Freaky Friday to do what see the
remake yeah True Lies versus Trading
Places Spencer smoke first Spencer 20
seconds begin whatever you speak now Tom
Arnold was robbed for a Best Supporting
Actor Oscar who beats your lies this is
this moving combines affection and
combines comedy Jamie Lee Curtis is
excellent in it this movies like The
Incredibles but with spies it's a
perfect fit broken family drama that's
healed and they then they heal that way
through exciting action through Pete
Schwarzenegger through Bey ham but
contained
Jerry Bruckheimer ham it's got really
everything you want from an
entertainment True Lies is a product of
its time it has not aged well
particularly in regards to Jamie Lee
Curtis
I think the Trading Places was the
happiest premise in the world that
captured one of the great comedy names
in America at the peak at his prime with
Eddie Murphy you have Dan Aykroyd again
it's about material and it's about a
memorable comedy this is one that could
have been lost to the ages but because
it has such it comes down to rewatch
ability for me I'd watch True Lies
anytime it's on cable I do think it
holds up as a piece of entertainment
whereas yours is a historical important
movie that you know the jokes work the
first time I don't really need to go
back and see Eddie Murphy do his thing
for the hundredth time time I don't
think that's historical importance I
think it's a classic comedy it has stood
the test of time I think True Lies is
dated it's an era of the big macho
action 90s classic comedies are timeless
I don't think true Liza's timeless
trading places at the time Louie I like
both of these movies a whole lot but
came down to the arguments and Dan had
several good takedowns and a good
argument for for his own I don't think
Spencer had to take down of his own
right there he had a good argument for
True Lies but I think Dan clearly took
the point for me Danielle I yeah these
are both really good points but I do
think that Dan
his argument about how dated true Liza's
now it's really hard because this one is
one of those ones where it's like cheese
and my babies but yeah I have to agree I
have to go again yeah no one brought up
you know dan aykroyd but has blackface
and trading play but no brought it up so
yeah but guys in True Lies indeed indeed
dan dan takes a lead three to two
this is game set and match point if Dan
takes this Spencer needs it to keep it
going alright question number four of
the speed round we got our first real
look at enter the spider-verse this week
what movie superhero that doesn't have
one deserves their own animated firsts
first universe yes
enter the whatever verse yeah what
superhero deserves their own animated
universe the blade averse weights I
Center the blade of Earth
is this a sari is a universe that's
populated like spider-man with versions
of them or is there we targeted I think
I think yeah it's like it doesn't have
to be doesn't have to be multi blows you
can come up with a verse that is not
whatever here versus there cast of
characters their cohorts I just want to
make sure that I just wanna make sure I
think we're pretty open we're pretty
loose to the to the verse after this yet
to the parameters of the verse I am
going to go with the Hulka verse okay oh
this is fun okay so uh Spencer with
blade Dan with Hulk Spence
twenty seconds begins whenever you speak
blades an r-rated movie I want to do a
hard are animated feature no kids gonna
accidentally wander under this one this
is gonna be an amazing in giuse Kroll
this is gonna be ultra violent like an
old-school hand-drawn 90s anime feature
you're gonna have Wesley Snipes voicing
because we don't know if we could still
do the moves but you can definitely
still do the voice he can still move
like crazy and animation and you they
created this whole blade cast of
characters I'm really time the worst
part was when they expanded the blade
cast of characters and blade Trinity
that movie lasted that friend has lasted
three movies and ran out of gas plus
it's nothing new about blade the
interesting about the Incredible Hulk
that's been constrained at the Cinematic
Universe is there are so many different
versions of that character the gray Hulk
the smart one the dumb ones use a way to
interact all of them together you can
bring in sheet hope you can bring in
more the supporting cast like Betty Ross
that I've been completely put away by
the movies look I would rather see that
live action we're not getting another
blade movie we can do it we can live on
this franchise and expand the universe
by pivoting to animation whereas the
Hulk isn't gonna be in seven movies a
year the Hulk doesn't work very well in
live-action that's why they struggled to
make a universe around him this is the
opportunity to make something of the
Incredible Hulk and actually put him in
a thing that in a context that makes
sense and in a format that makes sense
we seen bleed
time alright let's go long Harris I like
both of these I would totally enter but
either of these versus my house but
ultimately I really like Dan's argument
about there are there is already this
great cast of alternate hulks gray hope
she hope we never get to see these hoax
it would be fun to have an animated
universe where we could see a bunch of
different hulks so I'm going with them
I would argue that all right that's uh
104 Dan let's go Danielle Radford um I I
have to agree with Dan but not for
although as much as I do want to see all
of those and I really want to see that
she-hulk procedural drama I also Dan had
for me that that cutting line about how
as soon as the blade universe expanded
it ended the movie up so that was what
does that for me so I gotta go again Dan
Morell guess what you took the day what
a crazy turn of events but Dan you took
it in the speed round nicely done
never thought that little person there
you go yeah Dan go ahead and anything
exciting coming up anything on any
messages shoutouts etc thanks for
watching thanks for everybody that
watched this the first time and we're
still doing speed round questions from
our fundraiser and and and if you would
actually we did a video this morning on
screen junkies news kind of about the
state of online interaction and and fans
and is a conversation that I really
loved Ross Burnett and Danielle and
rocky stryer were there and I think it
was a really really great discussion and
if you have check it out yeah highly
recommend you don't you you guys delved
into like the Kelly Marie Tran issue and
everything do you think doors and the
internet yeah um a thoughtful s to you
this morning check it out Dan Congrats
well fought victory brother cucumber I'm
comin for you Oh
[Applause]
thank you for that reminder breaking
news y'all dan you are qualified in a
winner faces cucumber match so it's
going to be you Ed Grier and Clay's and
row if I'm not mistaken yes yes Dan
versus Ed Grier versus Coy's Andre
competitors will square off against our
puppet champion our felted from our
friend respect for our felted for
cucumber has the belt Spence
well fought Thanks go ahead and chime in
with some yeah give us a shout out give
us a weird non sequitur or anything you
want Hal I saw that Mark Wahlberg just
came out with some Air Jordans and I
thought about you wall burgers customs
like he gets like custom Jordans from
like we're like cuz he's from he's a
Boston guy we all know that so he gets
like weird green special Jordans and
stuff you let me win next time got a
parent it for it noted thank you I'm
gonna look those up check it out thanks
to the Tigers the wall burgers have you
eaten as anyone here eaten at wall
burgers I'd love to but I kind of want
to what No
[Music]
thank you sir super funny and well
fought as always Joestar oh man your
chair may be lowered but you are higher
in my esteem give us a like doing this
with these guys best part about this
show was yesterday us just having a very
long conversation as to what and what
did not define a ghost the most fun and
yes a married fan question nine years
yesterday happy University that's
awesome yes Joe has a lovely wife and
congratulations on your anniversary
thank you
yeah Lana Harris thank you for holding
it down over there we gave the wrong
link for Squarespace shut it down delete
it from your bookmarks it should be
Squarespace calm / screen junkies
logistics calm / screen Jackie's
cleavers and me dumpling thank you for
that clarification and I'll meet up with
you later we'll log in on that link and
make our owl sing yeah
Thomas take it so we'll go owls Bob
who's gonna who is going to check it out
Daniel Radford thanks for being awesome
as always what am I talking about what
happened this was really fun as you per
usual follow me on the Twitter's and the
IG at Daniele underscore Bradford this
was an amazing fight I'm really excited
and I love you all and I I'm sorry I
love you Joe oh let's go bullet Club is
fine yeah those guys are too sweet right
after the show you guys I want to thank
you for watching so much fun with the OG
screen junkies right here we'll see you
next week on movie fights bye bye
you